all right so Halloween ends is finally
here with the lumbering Michael Myers
having one last go at hattonfield and we
finally get the answer to the age-old
question does evil die tonight evil dies
tonight probably not they'll uh reboot
this in like five years but in this
video we're gonna be breaking down the
story the ending some of the Easter eggs
and theories along with our reaction and
review for this third installment in the
h4o trilogy Halloween kills took things
for a loop and honestly derailed the
flow of where the 2018 Halloween reboot
sequel rebook wall I don't know what
this messy timeline is anymore was
taking things but we do know one thing
Lori is a 40ish year obsession is
bringing the shape out for One Last Tour
so let's see if this Mike Myers has got
his mojo back now if you enjoy this
video then please stab that like button
as it helps the channel out and also
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
Easter eggs Theory video videos and
Recaps like this every day with that out
of the way a huge thank you for clicking
this now let's get into Halloween ends
[Music]
now Halloween kills ends in a Michael
Myers Battle Royale against the citizens
of Haddonfield with him coming out
Victorious claiming the heavyweight
Halloween belt and also Lori strode's
daughter Karen man the last few years
have not been great for Karen's instead
Halloween end starts with a bit of a
time Jump rather than picking up right
after the 2018 Halloween Massacre we
open on the following years 2019
Halloween with hints of Michael Meyer
having not been seen since that fateful
night this prologue in a sense sets the
tone of Hatton field only a year later
people of course still on edge along
with introducing a new character of
Corey Cunningham nerdy high schooler
going to college to become an engineer
in the fall now Jeremy and him watch
scary movies one of them being John
Carpenter's The Thing of course a nod to
Carpenter who directed the original
Halloween but also tying into the theme
of evil and you can never really tell
who it's in Jeremy plays a trick on
Corey which goes horribly wrong
resulting in the little boy Olympic Swan
diving three stories down pancaking
right in front of his unexpecting
parents this sequence and cinematography
feels similar to the stairwell scene
from the original 1978 film obviously
less graphic and sets up Corey's origin
story the opening title sequence kicks
in with the iconic John Carpenter theme
the font style and coloring with its
light blue pain homage to that of
Halloween 3's opening titles and again
we have the familiar pumpkin but with it
entirely being a different animation
from the previous two films 2018's
Halloween saw the pumpkin reverse
rotting almost symbolizing the franchise
returning to its former glory or reborn
after you know some not great sequels
Halloween kills pumpkin was a blaze
symbolizing total Carnage and ends shows
pumpkins morphing from within one
another bursting outward with
progressively more evil Expressions on
each that follows this symbolizes the
inner evils everyone has and how the
evil can spread but most notably how
Michael's Supernatural evil I I'm gonna
call it that because I I mean he's well
beyond being hangry spreads to Corey
corrupting him the year is now 2022 four
years after the Halloween Massacre from
the previous two films Lori gives us a
long drawn out speech which is a memoir
she is writing recounting all of the
events leading up to this film and how
hattonfield is almost cursed infecting
many of its citizens with grief blame
paranoia again leaning into that
Supernatural element to Michael and his
evil even though this film remains
grounded with its approach to everything
there's newspaper clippings recounting
the event from previous films obituaries
for Linda and Bob from the first film
The Manhunt for Michael and this night
blade Landmark refers to the working
title of the 2018 Halloween film the
radio DJ in the background is sort of
the explain everything away device here
asking how anyone could be shot and beat
on the street and still get up he's got
to be some sort of Supernatural beast
and mentions that Michael hasn't been
seen for four years he must be in
hibernation or something Corey is a
washed up failure in the eyes of
hattonfield because of the instant back
in 2019 he is bullied by High School
band members hold on did I just read
that right High School band members are
the jocks of the
2022s what the [ __ ] is going on anyway
this bullying connects Corey to both
Lori Strode and Allison whom he becomes
romantically involved with later in the
film but also the shape who is playing
the most elaborate game of where in the
world is Michael Myers Alison plays with
some tarot cards and draws the death
card which is a huge foreshadowing to
the ending of the film followed by now
that just means a major phase is ending
and a new one is about to begin so that
pretty much puts a nail in the coffin
with that of which hints at brighter
days in Alison's future but could also
be a heavy-handed hint at the franchise
going with her or adopting her as the
new Final girl we seemingly find out
Michael has been hanging out with his
pal Pennywise in the sewers after
dragging Corey into his TMNT layer we're
like 41 minutes into the movie we
haven't even seen him yet so uh
Michael's manager did not do great in
the contract negotiations but this is
where we see Michael kinda act out of
character from what we've seen in the
previous films showing empathy towards
Corey looking into his eyes he can see
the pain and hurt that he has gone
through and it's literally a Liam Neeson
dark man situation where essentially
Michael sees a new rightful heir to the
mask and injects his evil right into
Korea again in a grounded sense but the
supernatural energies are playing a big
role even if they want to be explained
as like evil hatred fear or any sort of
vile feeling we're supposed to believe
Michael has been in hiding ever since
the instant on Halloween 2018 but
there's a handful of hints here that I
think he's been killing on other
Halloween nights the biggest clue is
this missing Megan Baxter billboard
there was a handful of set photos with
this same billboard showing that she had
gone missing on Halloween 2001 so like a
wounded animal Michael has been hunting
but very much less uh grandiose Corey is
an inquisitive little murder man
learning from Michael which was cool to
see but because Michael is like feasting
almost surviving on this Carnage and
kills that he commits because before
this he looked like a decrepit old man
but then slowly starts to stand up
straight have more Force to him it's
like a visual representation of a video
game character filling up their special
meter looked wild Michael is in Corey as
he slowly begins to act more and more
like the shape honestly the two of them
are like Predators fighting over the
mask like a mama in her cub who will be
the alpha as Michael takes him under his
wing uh teaching him as the two go on a
Revenge trip that references events and
things from the previous films Allison's
co-workers are dispatched one with a
corkscrew referring to Charlie from H2O
and another pinned against the wall like
Bob in the original film Corey uses a
wrench which is a clever little Easter
egg to the original film because to
break the window when escaping from the
mental hospital a wrench was held in the
actor's hand you can see her breaking it
Ronald is watching Jean-Claude Van
Damme's Hard Target there's no reference
here I just think that it's a kick-ass
90s action movie treat yourself but at
the radio station the receptionist is
played by Diana Prince who plays Darcy
the male girl on the last Drive-In
Series yeah that's how I know her uh
Willie the kid also says resurrections
which is a hint towards Halloween
resurrection Corey also shows similar
qualities to Michael standing like him
outside of Lori's window earlier in the
film him sitting up like Michael after
falling off the radio station building
and spending the night in the abandoned
house where the kid died like Michael
did in his old home in the 1978 film
earlier in the film Allison also plays
what sounds like the first three notes
of the Halloween theme
the final person on this revenge tour of
death happens to be Lori though she she
tricks Corey shooting him as he falls
down the stairwell however it's all a
miscommunication as Alison thinks Lori
is the crazy one here leaving her to
fend off Michael all by her Lonesome
this whole encounter feels very
reminiscent of the 1978 encounter with
Lori hiding in the closet while also
wearing a very similar outfit that she
did in that film only this time she
completely surprises Michael now he
tries to put her hand in the garbage
disposal which is yet again another
reference to Halloween H2O I I thought
people did not like that movie why do
they keep referencing it but ends up
essentially crucifying him on the
kitchen counter this was sort of
foreshadowed by the homeless man and his
ramblings earlier in the film actually
Lori pulls off Michael's mask like a
Scooby-Doo villain but with one final
I'm not dead moment from Michael but
Allison Saves the Day breaking his arm
No Lie it is then a Michael Myers prey
around Haddonfield to let everyone know
that the monster is finally slain
seriously they strap him to their car
like a damn Christmas tree they drive
him to the junkyard and grind that some
beach up like some Savory ground pork
Lori finally lives in peace looking like
she and Hawkins might have you know an
item starting up Allison drives off to
start her own adventure which no doubt
will Ambiguously set up a sequel while
we now see different parts of Lori's
home in the Silence of daylight this
symbolizes that the terror is done
because the end of the original film
showcased rooms Michael had killed in
with the Drone of the theme playing in
the darkness of the night but now shows
that Lori is in better times her mind
can now be at ease there's a final shot
of Michael's mask as blue oyster Cults
Don't Fear the Reaper kicks in and the
credits Begin Again featuring the same
blue font from Halloween 3 but the song
has a few different meanings here first
is Lori having a fever and the only
prescription
I'm just messing around I had to do that
but the song does play in the original
1978 film when Annie and Lori are
driving around but the most obvious is
being that Lori no longer has to Fear
the Reaper AKA death aka the ship AKA
Mike Myers yeah baby yeah now there are
a lot of metaphors about hate in this
and how it can spread and affect
equating to the supernatural Powers
Michael possessed he was fueled by
hatred like many others after the events
in 2018. Corey breaking the bottle
leading to the tire smash his mother
yelling at him the woman at the grocery
store the bullies it's the whole concept
of the chain of screaming from How I Met
Your Mother but here they are equating
the events happening to an individual
person a victim and essentially victim
blaming therefore spreading to others
and morphs into hatred it's contagious
and when one Boogeyman disappears
another one takes their place evil
doesn't die sorry everyone that was
chanting that in Halloween kills evil
dies tonight but instead it changes
shape by by this logic they should not
have paraded Michael around like he was
some sort of sassy runway model as for
where they could take the Halloween
franchise next seems a bit Bleak with
Michael Myers being turned into
hamburger meat Hawkins you knew didn't
you the shape as we know it is gone but
the movie does paint the picture that
it's never Michael Myers character but
rather the evil that was in him the
supernatural evil that can spread from
person to person like we saw with Corey
it's forever going to be in Hatton field
a dread pirate Roberts approach where
the mask is the key so someone is going
to be corrupted by The Mask much like
Jim Carrey in the mask and the next
person is going to take on this mantle I
could see Allison's somehow returning
back to hattonfield for Lori's funeral
and in that case she has to go up
against whoever this next person is that
is reigniting all of these murders
that's sort of what I gathered from the
death tarot card about New Beginnings
they'll probably even call it something
like Halloween returns or some [ __ ] like
that just just you wait hell they could
even bring back Michael Myers bring him
back to life heavily leaning on the
supernatural elements saying that like
the person that actually died was his
the long-lost brother I don't know Nigel
Myers whatever they can do to keep this
franchise alive and continue making them
money am I Really Gonna defile this
grave for money
of course I am
honestly I thought Halloween ends landed
more in the realm of Halloween kills
than the 2018 Halloween there's some big
swings that they are going for but
ultimately it is more misses than hits
like the idea of this evil that spreads
like a virus is there but never fully
established instead leading into a faux
Bonnie and Clyde romance that I thought
was going to turn Allison fully against
Lori I liked the toned down version of
Lori and her settling back into an
actual life but Michael definitely went
out like a chump the final climax
between these two was lackluster at best
but I know that others out there are
going to love this there's some weird
ideas I can't deny that the Revenge
corrupted nature of Michael's evil is
going to resonate with some people but
for me it just not so much but obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on
Halloween ends and whether or not you
were disappointed by the lack of evil
dies to nights that were chanted
throughout we're currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
top gun Maverick on the 15th of November
and all you have to do to begin a chance
of winning this is like this video make
sure to subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below on your
thoughts of Halloween ends and kind of
this Trilogy in general we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of last months are
on screen right now so if that is you
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our other cool
videos right over there whether it be
our house of dragon coverage or our
She-Hulk finale breakdown with that out
of the way thanks for sticking through
this video I've been Jared and I'm gonna
go eat a whole bowl of Halloween candy
because
Werther's Originals the official candy
of old people I'll see you in the next
one take care and peace